Jeśli obracasz piłkę wokół jednej osi, a potem wokół drugiej, wynik nie jest taki sam jak w odwrotnej kolejności.
Dzisiaj w Qiskit in the Classroom zobaczymy, co ta piłka ma wspólnego z komputerami kwantowymi i jedną z najsłynniejszych
zasad mechaniki kwantowej – zasadą nieoznaczoności.
Witaj w Qiskit in the Classroom – serii filmów, w której omawiamy fundamentalne koncepcje, które możesz
napotkać na kursie związanym z quantum computing. Każdemu filmowi towarzyszy interaktywny moduł zlinkowany
w opisie poniżej, więc koniecznie go sprawdź. Dzisiaj mówimy o zasadzie nieoznaczoności Heisenberga. Jeśli
o niej słyszałeś, być może znasz też stary dowcip o Heisenbergu: pewnego dnia zatrzymała go policja i officer zapytał:
czy wiesz, z jaką prędkością jechałeś? Heisenberg odpowiedział: nie, ale wiem dokładnie, gdzie jestem. To niejako
zasada nieoznaczoności Heisenberga w pigułce – nie możesz jednocześnie znać pozycji i pędu cząstki
z doskonałą precyzją. Często zapisuje się to tak: delta x razy delta p jest większe
lub równe h/2, gdzie delta x i delta p to
niepewności pozycji i pędu, a h to mała stała fundamentalna w mechanice kwantowej.
Heisenberg sformułował tę nierówność w 1927 roku, wyobrażając sobie, jak zmierzyć pozycję elektronu. Jeśli
odbijesz od niego foton, by zobaczyć, gdzie jest, ten foton nieuchronnie kopnie elektron i zaburzy jego
pęd. To nie jest tylko stwierdzenie o tym, że pomiary zaburzają układ – mówi nam, że istnieją fundamentalne
ograniczenia w tym, ile możemy dowiedzieć się o przyrodzie. To jeden przykład szerszej zasady zwanej komplementarnością, która
mówi, że pewne aspekty przyrody są ze sobą niezgodne i nie mogą być obserwowane
jednocześnie. Na przykład obiekty kwantowe zachowują się czasem jak cząstki, a czasem jak fale,
ale nie możesz obserwować obu zachowań jednocześnie. Heisenbergowska relacja pozycji i pędu obejmuje tylko jeden
z wielu zestawów cech komplementarnych. Ta wrodzona nieoznaczoność ma związek z tym, jak postrzegamy właściwości takie jak
pozycja i pęd w mechanice kwantowej. Zamiast traktować x i p jako zmienne lub wewnętrzne właściwości,
które każda cząstka posiada, w mechanice kwantowej pozycja i pęd są operatorami. Nie są właściwościami
układu, lecz czynnościami, które można na nim wykonać. Poznanie pozycji cząstki wymaga teraz wykonania
operacji na tym układzie i dokonania pomiaru. Ta operacja może wpłynąć na wynik innych kolejnych
operacji. Jako analogię pomyśl o kawałku suchego drewna. Ma wiele właściwości, takich jak
pozycja, rozmiar, kształt. Ma też właściwość bycia palnym i pływającym na wodzie. Gdyby to drewno było
obiektem kwantowym, nie byłyby to właściwości, które możesz po prostu z góry znać. Zamiast tego powiedzielibyśmy, że są to
obserwable – rzeczy, o których możesz się dowiedzieć, wykonując pewną operację na układzie. Musiałbyś więc zastosować
operatory palności lub pływalności, co wymagałoby faktycznego próbowania spalenia drewna lub wrzucenia go
do wody, żeby sprawdzić, czy pływa. Wynik każdego z tych operatorów zależy od kolejności ich zastosowania. Jeśli
najpierw sprawdzisz palność, drewno spłonie na popiół i nie będziesz mógł sprawdzić, czy pływa. Ale jeśli najpierw sprawdzisz
pływalność, drewno będzie za mokre, żeby się palić. Mówimy, że operatory palności i
pływalności nie komutują – kolejność operacji ma znaczenie. Prowadzi to do fundamentalnego
ograniczenia w tym, jak dobrze obie obserwable mogą być znane dla kawałka drewna, bo nie możemy powiedzieć na pewno, czy jest palny
czy pływający, nie znając kontekstu pomiaru. Oczywiście z prawdziwym kawałkiem drewna
mógłbyś go przeciąć na pół i przetestować obie właściwości jednocześnie, ale z cząstką kwantową nic takiego nie możesz zrobić.
Ta analogia do drewna jest tylko analogią. Nieoznaczoność jest cechą wyłącznie kwantową. X i P też nie komutują
i ta właściwość nieprzemienności prowadzi do zasady nieoznaczoności Heisenberga. Ogólnie każde dwa operatory,
które nie komutują, mają swoją własną zasadę nieoznaczoności. Ogólną postać zasady nieoznaczoności można
zapisać tak: delta A razy delta
B jest większe lub równe
1/2 razy to nawiasowe wyrażenie z A i B, gdzie
ten nawias nazywa się
komutator i jest równy różnicy między zastosowaniem najpierw A, potem
B, a zastosowaniem najpierw B, potem A. Te nawiasy kątowe
sygnalizują, że bierzesz tak zwaną wartość oczekiwaną zawartości – zasadniczo, jeśli wiele razy wykonasz ten sam
pomiar, wartość oczekiwana to średnia ze wszystkich tych pomiarów. Dzisiaj
faktycznie przetestujemy i zweryfikujemy tę zasadę nieoznaczoności na komputerze kwantowym IBM. Przyjrzymy się trzem różnym
obserwablom qubitu, pokażemy, że ich operatory nie komutują, a na koniec będziemy mogli udowodnić, że zasada
nieoznaczoności zachodzi dla tych obserwabli qubitu. Najpierw krótka uwaga o pomocnym sposobie wizualizacji kwantowego
stanu qubitu. Można go reprezentować wektorem wskazującym pewne miejsce na sferze zwanej sferą Blocha. Omówiłem to
w poprzednim filmie zlinkowanym w opisie, ale szybko powtórzę. Oto
sfera Blocha. Każdy wektor jest sparametryzowany dwoma kątami: theta i phi.
Stan zero jest na biegunie północnym, a stan jeden na biegunie południowym. Równa superpozycja 0 i 1 leży
gdzieś na równiku, gdzie phi jest równe fazie względnej między dwiema częściami
superpozycji. Ten stan byłby więc równy
1/√2 |0⟩ + e^(iφ) |1⟩, gdzie i to ta
faza. Gdy mierzymy obserwablę qubitu, wynik zawsze jest jedną z dwóch opcji odpowiadających dwóm
możliwym stanom qubitu. W eksperymencie, który za chwilę przeprowadzimy, przyjrzymy się trzem obserwablom i
ich odpowiadającym operatorom: X, Y i Z. Gdy mierzysz którekolwiek z tych obserwabli, otrzymujesz albo plus jeden, albo
minus jeden, z prawdopodobieństwem zależącym od kąta między wektorem qubitu na sferze Blocha i
WEBVTT
osią pomiarową. Jak możesz się spodziewać, Z mierzy wzdłuż osi Z, X wzdłuż X,
a Y wzdłuż Y. Pamiętaj, że mówimy o obserwablach, bo przy układzie kwantowym
nie możemy po prostu wiedzieć rzeczy o układzie bez ich mierzenia.
Każda obserwabla ma odpowiadającą operację, bo pomiary wymagają operacji. Może nie być to oczywiste, ale
okazuje się, że operacje zwane operatorami odpowiadające każdej z tych obserwabli – x, y i z – to
obroty o pi wokół ich odpowiednich osi. X to obrót wokół X, Y
wokół Y, a Z wokół Z. Żeby sprawdzić, czy te operatory komutują, możemy sprawdzić, czy obroty
na sferze komutują. Jeśli tak, zasada nieoznaczoności nie będzie miała zastosowania i moglibyśmy znać X, Y i Z o qubicie
z doskonałą precyzją. Jeśli nie komutują, będziemy mogli znaleźć nową relację nieoznaczoności dla qubitu. Obserwuj
punkt na tej piłce, gdy obracam najpierw wokół X, a potem wokół Y. Trafia
tutaj. Teraz spróbujmy w odwrotnej kolejności: obracam najpierw wokół Y,
a potem wokół X. Trafia tam. Więc zdecydowanie nie komutują. Oznacza to,
że nie możemy jednocześnie znać dokładnych wartości X, Y i Z qubitu. Będziemy mieć
relację nieoznaczoności. Pominiemy szczegóły, ale ostatecznie dostajemy trzy różne relacje
nieoznaczoności. Mamy więc: delta X razy delta Y
jest większe lub równe Z; delta Y razy delta Z jest większe lub
równe X; a delta Z razy delta X jest większe lub równe
Y. Iloczyn dowolnych dwóch z tych niepewności jest zawsze większy lub równy
wartości oczekiwanej trzeciej obserwabli. Użyjmy Qiskit, żeby zobaczyć, co
się dzieje, gdy próbujemy zmierzyć zarówno Z, jak i X dla stanu zero. Mierzenie Z jest łatwe – to tak zwana baza standardowa;
pomiary na komputerze kwantowym są domyślnie wzdłuż Z. Ale żeby zmierzyć X, trzeba wykonać coś zwanego
zmianą bazy – obróć sferę Blocha tak, żeby X wskazywało ku górze, gdzie wcześniej stało Z. Do tego
używamy bramki Hadamard. Pełny quantum circuit wygląda tak: mierzymy w Z, stosujemy Hadamard,
a potem mierzymy w X. Jeśli użyjemy prymitywu Qiskit sampler, by uruchomić ten eksperyment wiele razy, dostajemy
histogram wyników pomiarów wyglądający tak dla pomiaru Z
i tak dla pomiaru w X. Jak widać, zmierzyliśmy
qubit jako stan zero wzdłuż Z z prawdopodobieństwem bliskim 100%, ale
wzdłuż X nie wiedzieliśmy praktycznie nic o stanie qubitu – był mierzony jako zero lub jeden z równym
prawdopodobieństwem, co oznacza, że nasza niepewność w X była niemal maksymalna. To daje nam
pewne poczucie tej zamiany niepewności, ale możemy zrobić nieco więcej na naszym komputerze kwantowym. Możemy użyć
prymitywu Qiskit zwanego estimator, by znaleźć wartości oczekiwane naszych obserwabli X, Y i Z oraz
niepewność każdej z nich. Wypróbujmy dla stanu wskazującego w kierunku plus X na sferze Blocha. Użyjemy estimator,
by obliczyć niepewności w x i z dla tego stanu oraz wartość oczekiwaną
Y. Dla tego stanu dostajemy taki wynik z Qiskit. Gdy bierzemy iloczyn dwóch
niepewności w X i Y, widzimy, że zgodnie z oczekiwaniami jest większy niż wartość bezwzględna
wartości oczekiwanej Y. Ale to było tylko dla jednego konkretnego stanu. Chcemy upewnić się, że ta nierówność zachodzi
dla wszystkich stanów qubitu. Użyjmy więc estimator ponownie, ale tym razem poprosimy go, żeby przeskanował wartości
parametru i znalazł wartości oczekiwane dla każdej podanej wartości parametru. Parametrem, który chcemy
skanować, jest kąt theta na sferze Blocha, żebyśmy mogli sprawdzić nierówność dla wszystkich stanów qubitu leżących na
tym łuku przecinającym płaszczyznę XZ. Gdy to robimy, dostajemy wykres w funkcji kąta theta. Czerwona
krzywa to iloczyn dwóch niepewności, a pomarańczowa – wartość oczekiwana Y. Zgodnie z oczekiwaniami
iloczyn niepewności w x i z jest znacznie wyższy niż wartość oczekiwana Y. Ale nie było
trudno spełnić tej nierówności, bo wartość oczekiwana Y była tak niska – wynosiła zero dla wszystkich stanów na
tym łuku. Zróbmy podobne skanowanie wartości theta, ale zamiast skanować w płaszczyźnie XZ, ustawmy phi równe pi/
4, żeby patrzeć na stany qubitu leżące na innym łuku na sferze. Tutaj nierówność jest
poddana ostrzejszemu testowi, bo pomarańczowa i czerwona krzywa są bliżej siebie, ale czerwona jest zawsze nad pomarańczową
i zasada nieoznaczoności nadal obowiązuje. Nie sprawdziliśmy jeszcze wszystkich stanów, ale mam nadzieję, że zaczynasz
rozumieć ideę. Istnieje fundamentalna niepoznawalność każdych dwóch komplementarnych aspektów kwantowego
układu, łącznie z tym qubitem, którego używamy. Zasada nieoznaczoności zmusza nas do zaakceptowania faktu, że bez względu na to,
jak bardzo się staramy, jak sprytne są nasze pomiary – nigdy nie będziemy wiedzieć wszystkiego z doskonałą precyzją.
Nie ma od tego ucieczki. Naprawdę. Jeśli mi nie wierzysz – albo nawet jeśli wierzysz – zachęcam cię: zajrzyj do modułu
zlinkowanego w opisie i spróbuj pokonać zasadę nieoznaczoności. Dzięki za oglądanie i do następnego razu.